giving gpt4 full access to my terminal
for some of you you're way too excited
about the prospects of such a thing and
this probably scares the heck out of
many others of you the idea is actually
pretty simple and safe we're really just
trying to make prototyping and r d with
gpt4 and models like it much more fluid
as it stands right now you might go to
the chat GPT UI or some other chat UI
and ask it for something like a
matplotlib graphing example you'll wait
for the generation and you'll copy and
paste it into an editor and then run it
and then maybe then you'll ask for some
changes more weight more copy and pasta
and so on what I want to do instead is
eliminate a lot of the sort of waiting
and going from prompt to result and and
I really want to just make this as
quickly happen as quickly as possible as
well as require as little effort as
possible while still reviewing what the
model actually wishes to do before
allowing it to to do that we can even do
the edit to Dark theme too in this way
for something so simple as just a
matplotlib example these are fairly
minimal Time Savings although I think
the effort is still pretty low
comparatively but you can also quickly
see that we issued one prompt and then
we waited for gpt4 to generate all the
commands at once Each of which would
have been a separate kind of manual back
and forth for us especially if we hit
some sort of error or we're just waiting
for something to happen but instead we
can review and run all of the commands
in one go as we continue to ask for more
complicated things or even projects that
might require multiple files or even
installations of packages in setting up
an environment or even as we want maybe
to modify those files this sort of
structure can wind up saving us a ton of
time and energy so let's see some more
fancy examples imagine that you found
some sort of model on hugging face like
this code completion a language model
from replit that's very lightweight and
you'd like to make a demo with it by
implementing the model into some sort of
locally hosted web page with a text form
input for the prompt and then some logic
to display the output you know the
continued text some very common use case
for this particular model
so probably gpt4 really first needs to
know what model do we want to use and
then maybe do some light reading on the
model's page to understand a bit about
you know how to actually work with this
model temp GPT doesn't have any web
parsing ability built in but it can
program for us and we can certainly
parse with a program so we can start off
by asking temp GPT to do just that for
us and it does this first by installing
beautiful soup for python making the
directory we asked for and then writing
some web scraping code to get the text
from that page and then saving it to the
text file that we requested we can then
use term GPT to read that content dot
text file and create a web app for us
that demos its abilities we did hit an
error along the way which I just copy
and paste to term GPT both times and it
is fixed this is one thing I'm
considering fully automating and I'm
trying to do that by allowing term GPT
to read the terminal outputs to
determine if more commands or changes
need to be made if an error is at least
detected the error and suggestion in the
error text here could have been ingested
by term GPT to easily Implement and fix
not really much different than us
copying and pasting the error ourselves
anyway after reading the error term GPT
finds a way to remedy the problem and
our program works this has been
extremely minimal with effort compared
to what I would have done even if I was
either traditionally doing this by hand
or even via the chat UI for chat GPT and
we can definitely do this in in even
more like less clunky way speaking of
which how about a web parser idea can we
use term GPT to modify a pre-existing
project absolutely might we actually use
term GPT to modify itself to add
something like a web parser here I asked
term GPT to implement a web parsing
feature similar to my file reading
feature and it modifies multiple areas
of the term GPT script to do this
testing this feature we can ask term GPD
to parse some web page and then save a
summary of that text to file for example
let's parse the readme page from GitHub
for tensorflow and see if gpd4 can
summarize it for us into one sentence
about what tensorflow is in this case
though it is plausible that gpt4 could
also just have used its own underlying
knowledge of tensorflow for example we
could just outright ask gpt4 about
tensorflow without any other context and
it could summarize into one sentence
instead let's ask about something newer
so we could ask about stable Studio from
stability AI asking gpt4 via the chat UI
and it looks like this time gpt4 doesn't
actually know which makes sense this is
relatively new and gpd4's knowledge
stops in like late March or something
like like that so then we can go back to
our example parse that readme and get a
good summary of it okay so those are
just some really quick examples of
what's possible and to be honest this
has all just been kind of my first
attempts as I'm trying to kind of make
this happen as this is a common at least
personally workflow for me and I really
just wanted to stop you know
highlighting or clicking copy code paste
run copy some error go back like all
this like back and forth was getting
very old and I really just wanted to
come up with a solution that would just
automatically kind of do these things
for me execute the commands for me all
of that so this is really my first run
through and there are for sure going to
be better ways to do the things that I'm
doing here and
um I definitely there's lots of things
that we could build on and I'm going to
be hosting this code so if you have
ideas or things you want to try feel
free to fork or submit a pull request or
anything like that so with that let's go
ahead and dive into the code and see how
everything is working under the hood all
right so here with the code let's go
ahead and run through how everything
works so first we we've just got a bunch
of imports open AI for the API of course
colorama to make things pretty time for
a sleep context this is how I'm setting
the pre-prompt we will come to that in a
moment but for now that's just that's
it's the pre-prompt uh sub process this
is for attempting to execute commands
and get their output I'm still
struggling with this maybe someone can
help me figure out what the heck why
this doesn't work I'm sure it's probably
some super simple logic problem but
anyway uh re for regular Expressions uh
requests and beautiful Soup for the web
parsing capability that term GPT
actually added for itself
um again and this actually isn't really
all that required uh since we
term GPT can already write a web parser
but the real kicker here is you know it
could also write code to open up a file
but what you want to be able to do is
read that information into context so
doing that I think still kind of
requires these features but I want to
kind of clean this up and quite possibly
make it a little more Dynamic so for
example like pulling from a website do
you do you really just want the
paragraph text do we want to also handle
for JavaScript that happens to populate
things you know so this is a really
basic example but this won't get you
very far so anyway I'm still kind of
thinking about how I really want to do
that but anyway moving along the open AI
key uh really all the open AI stuff I've
got a video on that I'll try to remember
to put a link in the description for the
basics of working with that API
um but anyway that's where our key is
debug this is just for a few extra print
statements uh just to uh mostly for
outputting the full context every time I
query gpt4 just because that'll tell you
for sure what exactly you're sending and
getting back I find that to be the
biggest amount of information that you
don't always want to see but if you're
having a problem you probably want to
see that whole thing so anyway moving
along message history is that terminal
commands that's just like the from the
context that initial stuff that comes in
um and then we have the regular
expression pattern for the sort of
functionality of reading a file or
reading a website so this is just read a
file this is W for website
um it's just going to follow that again
we really could use uh large language
models to also parse this out and it
wouldn't even need to be struck like
super structured in any way it could
just read some text and then determine
is there a file that should be read if
yes you know read that file add that in
so you don't necessarily have to do it
this way again more on that and the
context and all that stuff in a little
bit because eventually I would like to
do this without using open AI I'd like
to use an open source model so I just
don't want to get too deep into prompt
engineering with gbd4 when I'm I'd like
to I'm kind of like Holding Out for a
really solid open source model with a
solid license so no llama uh anyway
moving along gbd query so this is pretty
much nothing new since the uh GPT 4 or
tutorial so again if any of this is
confusing to you other than maybe the
colorama stuff this just sets a color
sets uh styling basically does the text
whatever and then resets it back to
normal so that's just that's just
typical colorama stuff uh but anyway if
the debug is true we are sending the
entire message history which is the full
context that we're sending off to gpt4
so if anything's not working the way
we're expecting that's the first thing
that we're going to do so for example
reading the console outputs like trying
to get the return on in the console uh
it doesn't give the most recent command
no matter how hard I try so
I don't know at first I thought it was
while I'm hitting errors and I was I was
thinking the error is causing my problem
but I'm pretty sure I'm handling it such
that you would still you should still
capture the error but for some reason
I'm just not so anyway
um moving along so this is just a query
gpd4 API
extract paragraphs this is the code that
uh gpt4 Slash term GPT wrote and
modified into our script for us uh just
simply reads the website grabs all the
paragraph text so really really basic
again I think this should be a little
better
um but moving along so then we've just
got some pretty colorama stuff welcome
to term GPT
um it just tells you kind of the point
of term GPT is just to make prototyping
faster not a whole bunch of other fancy
stuff it's just make prototyping and r d
really quick but don't run commands
without still being able to review them
so
um continuing along so this is just some
more color color stuff you've seen what
it outputs already so then we get the
input whatever the user wants to you
know put in the command and then we have
these very simple ones like clear this
just clears out that whole contextual
history and just resets us back to
terminal commands we'll talk about we'll
I'll show those momentarily output this
reads theoretically the output from the
system basically in the terminal what
you know what was the response back to
that terminal what was printed out in
that terminal so if you did hit an error
it would be nice to be able to say
output or you know call this command and
then it would read that rather than you
needing to copy and paste in the error
but again it's not really working so got
a copy and paste there still
um otherwise uh what it's going to do is
it's going to look for any matches for
do we want to read any files and it can
do any number of files and then
essentially what it's going to do is
either for files or websites that text
that it parses it's just going to shove
it in and just it's going to build that
context and so it's just going to
populate that context with the actual
text so it just adds it in so you'll say
I have this file here and then you'll
say you'll have like the read command
and it will quite literally say the file
name and then the content of the file so
again no different than what you would
say hey I've got this python file here's
the code copy paste you paste in the
code this is the same exact thing it
just builds that context for me so once
we have that user input which is going
to be you know please help me make a
Flash website or please help me do you
know whatever it is we have that user
input we're going to send that off to
GPT and we're essentially going to wait
until GPT is done so what does that mean
so now it's time to go to our context so
this is the pre-prompt that I'm using to
force gpt4 to behave in the way that I
want so essentially this is all sent off
and this is how the program begins so
we're starting off by just telling gpt4
let me add word wrap real quick make
this a little easier on us we're saying
as if I had told it you know given text
input from a user looking to do
programming helped me build a series of
console commands that will achieve the
goals of the prompt your responses will
come one command at a time where each
response is just the command and nothing
else when ready for the next command the
user will say next all caps next and you
will respond with the next command when
we have reached the end of console
commands respond with done and then you
will do it again with some new input
from the user if you understand say okay
and again we're just forcing the
assistant here uh you know to think
historically it said okay
and then what I'm doing is a One-Shot
kind of example I did find gbt4 to be
pretty good at following this command
but very often it's still added
commentary to the commands and all that
and yes we could use literally a large
language model to parse out the command
still
I don't like that so I wanted to do at
least a one shot I thought maybe it
might take more but a one shot gives us
an opportunity
to show it even more basic stuff so like
for example in this case we're using cat
to write to these files but there's lots
of ways that this could have been done
but given all of the huge variability of
stuff that can happen inside of a script
it would likely break many of the
methods that might be used to populate a
file so this one is just the one that
works so it allows us to kind of still
kind of show really what we're looking
for so for example with such a basic
thing is show me a basic flask web dev
example with templates right
and the first command in this case we're
making this up we're showing gpt4 how we
want it to behave so we're saying if
someone asked this here's an example of
the or sequence of events that should
occur first you're going to need to pip
install flask and then the user is going
to say next and then gpd4 is going to
respond with you're going to want to
make a directory basic flask app next uh
so we're gonna you know so already we're
trying to get it to kind of put this
into specific project folders
then what it's going to do is actually
write you know and then into that
directory and then app.pi uh it's going
to add just a very basic app.pi with
some template examples thank you
um and then okay that's that's what it
says and then the user next and then it
wants to make a template stir add that
index.html next blah blah you get the
idea all the way down to actually
running that app.pi the user says next
and actually we're done because we've
run the app so it's just a really simple
example that we're showing gpt4 this is
how I want you to respond every time and
then if that way if the user did happen
to say clear or whatever we just reset
right back to this context and continue
on but I found that you can generally
keep going pretty far and be totally
fine but if you are experiencing weird
things you would just clear it and start
over but anyway
coming over here while not GPT done so
GPD done starts as uh uh where the heck
are you here because we haven't started
a new input so we're going to start a
GPT done equals false so then what's
going to happen is as long as that's
true what we're going to do is we're
going to wait for the next command from
the user right and essentially it's
going to just inject that so we don't
need to say next we're just going to
automatically tell GPT 4 next in the
script and we're just waiting until we
literally see reply content.lower the
only reason I'm doing this gpd4 always
did and all caps done it was good
um but chat GPT for example I was just
trying between the two of them to see if
could we save some money
it would sometimes lowercase sometimes
add a period so I was like trying to
handle for that but again gpt4 uh really
follows this very well I'm sure I could
come up with ways to structure things
such that chat GPT or GPT 3.5
works I there's no reason in my head
that this couldn't be done with chat GPT
but gbd4 is just way better than chatgpt
so anyway moving on
um so if it has reached a done then we
set done to True cool and we break out
and then essentially all the way up to
this point we've been every time we get
a command we've been adding that command
to a list of commands right here
once we have that list of commands you
could have been theoretically running
them getting the return
and plausibly adding this to the context
or something just to see did you hit an
arrow along the way I think that's a
mistake because either you're gonna have
to sit there and keep clicking like next
or saying next or whatever or you're
going to be blindly running commands and
you're probably more likely to just kind
of blindly just hit go go go and I don't
think that's a good idea so so we're
going to build that that whole list and
then we're essentially going to iterate
through that whole list pretty printing
it out in bold red making it clear what
the commands are that are going to be
run and then
um
and then if we want to actually run
those commands then we are going to go
ahead and iterate through all of them
and run them and this is where I'm
attempting to get the actual output this
does work all the way up to I believe
the last output I need to look a little
deeper into that and see if it's there's
got to be something wrong with my logic
or something like I feel like this
should work but for whatever reason it's
just not working so anyway if the person
if the user puts in anything other than
y here it just okay it just doesn't run
the commands and that's fine
um sometimes still it does suggest to
you it might still give you some text
especially I found that to be true with
the console output it'll just say oh I
didn't find any errors or something like
that so it doesn't say done like it
should but anyway
um that's all there is to it all of the
Power of this this is all just a bunch
of stupid logic really around what is
the pre-prompt and what we can do with a
pre-prompt is I mean there's essentially
infinite pre-prompts that we could
theoretically use there are better
examples plausibly that we could show it
and there's more capabilities that we
could show it or teach it or even just
kind of that might show up so even given
this really basic example I have found
term GPT using gpt4 to be
um really impressive it really hasn't
let me down on any task yet certainly
there's really nothing that gpt4 could
do for me via like the chat UI that I
haven't been able to just do via term
GPT and it just it's just been so much
easier and again I made this really for
myself and I'm just sharing it with
people
um and it's for sure a work in progress
there are some relatively new open
source large language models that I'd
really like to see can can they fill in
this Gap because like I said even chat
GPT
is weak-ish at this again I think I
could come up with prompts that chat GPT
or GPT 3.5 rather could be successful
with
um so I I just I don't want to put in a
bunch of time making chat gbt work I'd
rather it be some sort of Open Source
model with a permissive license so
anyway stay tuned for that and again I
will put everything up on GitHub uh feel
free to make a fork or whatever or make
pull requests and and just uh kind of
Tinker with this I think this is kind of
cool I like the idea of going back and
forth like this and
just doing the r d with gpd4 but just
removing all of that extra effort it's
been it's been really fun using it so
anyway
um hopefully you guys will enjoy if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever suggestions uh feel free to
leave them below otherwise I will see
you all in another video if you've ever
wondered and wanted to know more about
how neural networks actually work
including the optimization and fitment
rather than just simply calling some
method then you might be interested in
checking out the neural networks from
scratchbook by myself and Daniel kukiwa
the book can be had in the form of an
ebook PDF softcover or hardcover and we
ship for free worldwide also the
physical books just come with an ebook
copy all copies are in full color which
helps because there's a lot of code
syntax highlighting and lots of charts
and diagrams to help convey the
principles also almost all of those
charts and diagrams have QR codes and
links that take you to animations to
help further illustrate the concepts
this is truly a real neural networks
from scratch teaching everything from
the forward pass calculation of loss
back propagation and optimization the
only math that you're expected to know
coming in is basic algebra the rest is
taught by us in the book step by step
everything is shown and explained in the
book first logically then mathematically
then via raw python code no third-party
libraries and then finally optimized via
numpy and this is for every step of the
way building and training actual neural
networks for a fully fundamental
understanding of neural networks and how
they work from scratch if at any point
you're lost or confused all copies of
the book also Grant access to a Google
Docs version of the book where you can
ask your questions in line with the
actual text itself this is an incredible
project that I'm extremely proud of to
share with you all we've sold over 13
000 copies to students all over the
world if you're looking to take your
knowledge of deep learning to the next
level or if you're just looking to start
that Journey I can't imagine a better
way so to learn more and buy yourself a
copy you can head to nnfs.io